hello there welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul and may the
fourth be with you because we have the
new obi-wan trailer which is just
dropped online unfortunately this is a
very very busy week for me we've got the
moonlight finale multiverse of madness
tomorrow the avatar trailer on monday i
believe and obi-wan today so disney
they're just like let's just put all of
this out there which is a bit annoying
and i don't think i'm gonna have time to
do a full breakdown this week however i
thought i'd give you something so i'm
gonna react to the trailer possibly go
through some of the easter eggs in it
point out some of the little hidden
details and then hopefully enjoyed
please hit the thumbs up button if you
do i know this isn't the typical content
that i tend to do but so many people
would have been bombarding me asking
where this video is so i thought i just
put something out let's get into it
without the way
that coming
i am at the moment as well stay hidden
i shouldn't have said that but we will
not survive
[Music]
like you trained his father you son of a
[ __ ]
he's gone
[Music]
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places
i want every lowlife and bounty hunter
to squeeze him
[Music]
i'll get you oh he's in it
[Music]
let's get it let's get it
hey that was a nice disney plus logo the
way they've done that so yeah quite a
good um good trailer that wasn't it do
you want to do you want to go back
through it with me i i feel like there's
a lot of footage that we've seen before
but
yeah there are some nice moments in it i
wasn't completely you know blown away
massively but i've i've got goosebumps
but i did want to see obi-wan and darth
vader fighting but you know save it for
the show that's fair enough now let's go
i love i love that song that's my
favorite song
yeah so this is the first time i think
canonically that we might have seen
stormtroopers obviously rogue one had
them in um but this is kind of shifting
over from the bad batch um definitely
check out that that first season if you
haven't seen it there the ending of it
especially is very emotional they
destroy basically to poker city which is
where all the clones are made and
yeah you kind of watch throughout that
season the shift between using
conscripted clones to
to these troopers i think they're
conscripted as well i'm a bit you know
what i'm a bit kind of
i might have downplayed how much i like
this trailer initially at my my skin's a
bit you know when you when your hair
stands up on end i'm feeling quite good
about myself for once
they're coming
okay so there's the grand inquisitor
you've got river on the left or might be
your right and i think you've got what i
believe is fifth brother looking very
menacing kind of rolling into town um i
love the way the black just contrasts
against the white of the
whatever location this is i think it
might either be mos eisley or moses but
it looks more like mos eisley because
moses was in book of boba fett and it
was slightly toned back but yeah just
just love this striking image and you
have kind of the civilians to the side
and you've got the inquisitors rolling
in taking up the position of power in
the middle really really nicely put
together
stay hidden
yeah and they're kind of questioning the
the the local town people that woman she
she looks really suspicious i wonder
what she's hiding at she's got she's got
baby yoda under that coat i'll tell you
but we will not survive
so the way obi-wan is talking there
where he says stay hidden or we will not
survive he's either talking to
luke or he might be talking to another
jedi now that could be ahsoka it could
be yoda that is quite an interesting one
because it doesn't sound like something
he'd say to luke because he's not yet a
jedi so him saying stay hidden
my tease another another character
showing up
worst breakdown ever don't know who it
is but just keep guessing
and there's luke
and then we've got uncle owen he's like
bloody i tell you what leave me kids
alone and so he's popped up quite a lot
in the the expanded law especially the
comic book series in that jab of the hut
and started putting attacks on moisture
farmers obi-wan showed up was like i'm
gonna just put an end to this no one has
to pay any extra money own laws after
that point had kind of been like i hate
this old man he keeps looking over my
kids every time i look up he's sitting
watching through binoculars it's a bit
creepy which is understandable um so
yeah
so so owens kind of telling him to back
off but in the the expanded law black
resentment showed up to collect the
money that had been you know not being
paid and that's kind of when obi-wan
beat the crap out of him and they were
like yeah you know what you are
protecting luke you protecting my family
which i appreciate until until those
stormtroopers show up and burn us alive
when the time comes he must be trained
like you trained his father
yeah
barely kicking the balls
so the way they're saying there you
still want kenobi i'm guessing that's
someone talking to vader obviously you
know kenobi is kind of the one who got
away beat the crap out of him left him
for dead and you can definitely
understand why he's still hunting this
guy and sending every single person that
he has after him really really nice
touch also i think in the top corner
there there might be some lightsabers by
the looks of it lightsaber handles don't
know but yeah nice
gone he's riding his yoke there
obviously that the characters appeared
on that quite a lot very very nice to
have in the trailer appeared in the
first one but yeah just kind of
following up on that
[Music]
and there if you listen very very very
closely there's the little probe dried
noise you know the one that they've been
immediate i don't know what to say but
it's out of the system something like
that down with the system down with a
rhythm
[Music]
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places
and rather she's clearly revving up to
to take him down and i believe she did
mention bounty hunters after this bit um
and they're clearly sending them after
obi-wan she's
just looks really menacing looking over
this city really nice shot
little wanted poster there really nice
i've wanted this series for a long time
every low life and bounty hunter
to squeeze him
[Music]
you see obi wan there using a blaster um
i believe in the first trailer he had
one as well and it looked like he was
having a shootout on the rooftop there
so
you know the guy's going back to those
barbaric weapons he was slagging off and
might not break out his lightsaber
because the second that he does it's
gonna bring like if he's fighting say
six or seven stormtroopers
you know
they're gonna report back if one of them
survives well we got shot at if he busts
out a lightsaber and they report back
that a guy with a lightsaber attacked us
he is screwed so can totally understand
why he's using a blaster
and there's also a probe droid destroyed
in the background there which is clearly
been searching for him so yeah really
nice little shot there
again didn't know come on then johnny
was in it and he's got what looks like a
little little droid there it looks a bit
like a pit pit droid head that with a
little eye in the middle a cyclops one
yeah kind no idea he was in it very
exciting
and then we see of course darth vader
getting put together he's got the the
robot hand i don't think you've ever
seen it stripped down that much
nice
[Music]
and this is where i got the chills
you say oh crap
that guy who breathes really loudly
yeah lovely really nice well done disney
got me hyped up quite a short trailer
only a minute and a half but
yeah thanks good job okay so that was
the trailer what did you think should i
do more videos like this when i don't
have time to work because i want to
spend time with my kids please just let
me spend some time with my kids just
just one minute please let me know below
and just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man noe home on
the 15th of may all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video drop a comment below and make sure
you subscribe to the channel with
notifications on the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch we've got the
moonlight finale on screen right now
we're doing multiverse of madness
tomorrow so make sure you stay locked
and i'll love you forever may the forth
be with you take care peace